und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend um in sachen corona zur
abwechslung mal mit einer guten
nachricht zu beginnen
gestern wurden hierzulande mehr als
700.000 menschen geimpft einen
tagesrekord
der zeigt was möglich ist wenn im stoff
da ist doch epidemiologen warnen selbst
wenn beim impfen jetzt wirklich tempo
rein käme werden davon allein die zahlen
sobald nicht runtergehen
im moment gehen sie ja eh steil nach
oben binnen 24 stunden wurden dem
robert-koch-institut 29 1426
neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind 9000 19
mehr als vergangenen donnerstag 293
menschen sind in verbindung mit quid 19
gestorben
die sieben tage incidents ist weiter
gestiegen und liegt aktuell bei 160,1
man kann gewissermaßen zu gucken wie das
eintritt wo vorgewarnt wurde walter
spiekermann berichtet jeder tag zählt
eine aussage die heute von diesen drei
männern geteilt und der öffentlichkeit
mit einer gewissen dramatik mitgeteilt
wird ein notruf ein ruf nach mehr tempo
shutdown für alle
das wäre aus ihrer sicht das beste klar
ist wir müssen jetzt handelt jetzt auf
allen ebenen und natürlich auch
besonders oft der ebene der entscheider
es ist gut dass wir mit der notbremse
per bundesgesetz bald eine einheitliche
und nachvollziehbare regelung haben aber
wir sollten nicht darauf warten bis der
bundestag nächste woche dieses gesetz
beschlossen hat nur noch 10 prozent frei
intensiv bett kapazitäten das bedeutet
pro intensivstation genau ein wert
dieses geld haben sich für den
schlaganfall für den herzinfarkt
patienten für den unfall patienten für
den operierten patienten und für den
kurven patienten das ist die situation
wie sie im moment ist sie will die macht
der länder an sich ziehen bundesweite
notbremse bundesweite ausgangssperren
doch selbst juristen aus dem kanzleramt
kritisieren laut bild zeitung den
entwurf als angreifbar ausgangssperren
hätten keine belegte wirksam
dazu kommt widerstand aus der eigenen
fraktion widerstand in den eigenen cdu
geführten ländern
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
meldete bereits erheblichen
gesprächsbedarf an
sachsen-anhalts regierungschef war und
kein mensch werde mehr mitmachen
jetzt sollen bilder überzeugen
vizekanzler scholz stellte sich heute an
die seite der mediziner und damit noch
einmal demonstrativ auf die seite des
bundes shutdowns er versichert
geschlossene spd rein verspricht ein
wasserdichtes bundesgesetz die
verfassungsressorts haben sich intensiv
mit der frage beschäftigt wie das gesetz
zu bewertendes und wir sind alle zu dem
ergebnis gekommen dass das eine
zulässige richtige und auch
verfassungsfeste lösung ist dass sie
berlins regierender bürgermeister müller
spd ganz anders ausgangssperren sei
nicht verhältnismäßig ein so massiver
grundrechtseingriff carsten schneider
auch spd warnt gar vor einer eskalation
der sozialen situation selbst das wort
verfassungsbeschwerde feld ferdinand
kirchhof war vizepräsident am
bundesverfassungsgericht er kritisiert
man könne eine gesellschaft auch zu
todesschützen neben der gesundheit gebe
es noch andere grundrechte
was mir an dem gesetz wie auch schon an
der früheren fassung missfällt ist dass
die grundrechte der anderen beteiligten
also der gewerbetreibenden der künstler
alle die sich in der öffentlichen und
privaten gesellschaft bewegen dass die
nicht berücksichtigt werden sondern das
sehr eindimensional nur an die virus
bekämpfung denkt hinter den kulissen
wird weiter verhandelt morgen erste
debatte im bundestag
es ist eine abwägung zwischen dem was
notwendig und dem was vertretbar
erscheint eine schwierige gratwanderung
wenn von bundes- notbremse die rede ist
klingt das ja fast ein wenig so als
könnten die bundesländer nicht selbst
bremsen ziehen
das könnten sie aber durchaus keine
landesregierung ist beispielsweise
gezwungen individuelle öffnungs modelle
auszuprobieren
sie könnten sich auch alle an die
verabredungen aus den mpk runden halten
und zb die hunderte regel umsetzen wenn
sie das für richtig halten
hamburg etwa tut das was im entwurf für
das bundesgesetz steht wird an der
alster bereits praktiziert sogar die
besonders umstrittene nächtliche
ausgangssperre
das ist in zweierlei hinsicht
interessant zeigt inwieweit die bürger
mitmachen und es zeigt dass auch diese
maßnahmen nicht so stark sind dass die
zahlen in hamburg schlagartig nach unten
gehen würden ist einrichten berichtet
diese bilder sind von heute abend in
hamburg hat die 14 8 in folge mit einer
ausgangs beschränkung begonnen bis
morgen früh um fünf darf nur hier
draußen sein wer einen triftigen grund
hat und alleine unterwegs ist die
polizei kontrolliert das allerdings gab
es bislang nicht viel zu kontrollieren
das ist natürlich immer schwer jetzt
wissenschaftlich ursache genau zu
ermitteln
aber seitdem wir die maßnahmen noch
einmal verschärft haben das war ja
unmittelbar vor ostern
seitdem haben wir unter dem strich
rückläufige infektionszahlen während der
bundestrend in die andere richtung geht
das gilt heute zum ersten mal allerdings
nächtliche ausgangsbedingungen
alkoholverbot in der öffentlichkeit
masken pflicht in vielen bereichen
wer die zeichen der pandemie in hamburg
sehen möchte der kommt an den symbolen
nicht vorbei der stadtstaat hat so
manche reißleine zuerst gezogen doch das
virus so trotzdem weiter gestern am
stadtpark drei familien mit kindern
schön fußballclubs spielplan solchen
ecken wo sich das so knobel tja sollte
man bestimmt mehr kontrollen
kontrollieren wir wohnen im
süderelberaum und wir fünf kilometer
entfernt von der landesgrenze zu
niedersachsen
wir sind gestern in buxtehude gewesen in
einem großen kaufhaus konnten da
einkaufen und die haben das wunderbar
geregelt in hamburg sind die kaufhäuser
zu aber die schulen offen hamburg hat
keine ferien hamburg hat wechsel
unterricht die klassen sind geteilt und
zweimal die woche getestet aber es sind
nur die abschlussklassen einen vollen
betrieb traut sich die stadt nicht mit
folgen wie überall
ja ich mache mir eigentlich und das hat
auch meine eltern ratssitzung gezeigt um
die jahrgänge 5 zum beispiel die letztes
jahr hier angefangen haben die erst mal
so eine bindung an die schule bekommen
müssen da mache ich mir eigentlich
größere sorgen deswegen würde ich mir
schon wünschen dass man die anderen
jahrgänge auch wenigstens mal für eine
klassenrat stunde einfach in die schule
holen kann ihnen dieses feeling von dass
es unsere schule geben kann
auf den intensivstationen kommen die
patienten die taktung steigt trotz aller
maßnahmen eine taktung die den
medizinern sorgen bereitet obwohl die
gut ausgestattete hansestadt noch weit
von einer übertaktung entfernt ist
aber man sieht eigentlich schon seit
februar einen langsamen aber
kontinuierlichen anstieg über ganz
hamburg hinweg den wir auch bei uns in
unserem krankenhaus genauso sehen und
wir versuchen uns so gut wie es geht zu
helfen zum beispiel durch übernahme von
patienten aus krankenhäusern bei denen
gerade die intensivstation voll ist
gerade heute übernehmen wir zwei
patienten aus umliegenden häusern
auch in hamburg wird es also eng drinnen
und draußen die stadt hält sich auch mit
viel kontrolle an alle incidence
grenzwerte und wird dafür belohnt etwas
und auch erst seit heute
ja und die warme vorbelasteten kliniken
ist mancherorts eben auch schon real von
dort kommen dann patienten die zum
beispiel nach hamburg gebracht werden wo
noch etwas geht darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit professor michael bauer ist
chefarzt am jenaer klinik für
intensivmedizin guten abend professor
bauer
guten abend herr slomka bei ihnen
thüringen ist die situation schlimm und
sie haben heute nachmittag mit einer
meiner kolleginnen aus dem thüringer
landesstudio gesprochen am telefon und
da sagten sie bei uns brennt die hütte
das ist korrekt wir sind seit wochen im
ausnahmezustand
die hälfte meiner betten sind aktuell
mit schwerstkranken patienten mit 19
belegt und im gegensatz zu den letzten
wochen sinkt der altersdurchschnitt
kontinuierlich das sind menschen mitten
aus dem leben der altersdurchschnitt ist
mitte fünfzig wir haben eine junge
patientin die frisch entbunden hat samt
dem kind auf der intensivstation wir
haben 32 jährigen fitnesstrainer bei uns
beatmet auf der intensivstation
leute mitten aus dem leben gerade das
wird mancher auch überraschen also
manche leute glaubten vielleicht auch na
ja wenn die pflegeheime erstmal durch
geimpft sind und die über 80-jährigen
weitgehend durch geimpft dann ist das
für den rest alles nicht mehr so
gefährlich und jetzt liegen da
schwangere und 30 jährige fitnesstrainer
bei ihnen das ist korrekt die gute
nachricht ist die impfung wirkt aber mit
den neuen varianten b17 der
südafrikanischen et cetera gibt es
durchaus schwere verläufe auch bei
jungen patienten und mit den
ansteigenden zahlen und da sind wir hier
in thüringen in der sehr ungünstigen
situation dass die institute seit
monaten hoch ist kommt es zu schwersten
erkrankungen auch bei jungen patienten
mitten aus dem leben
das ist dann sozusagen auch die die die
wucht der großen zahlen gibt es ja auch
stimmen die sagen nach instanzen das
kommt manchmal auch nur weil in einer
fleischfabrik zum beispiel sich leute
angesteckt hat man sollte lieber auf die
bettenbelegung gucken und darauf wie
viele menschen tatsächlich erkranken das
ist wahrscheinlich aus ihrer perspektive
dann eher schwierig oder wir sehen mit
einer erheblichen verzögerung die
patienten auf der intensivstation mir
ist angst und bangen die zahlen steigen
auch bei uns in der region weiter und
wir haben einen kontinuierlichen
nachschub von schwerstkranken patienten
andere bundesländer die jetzt nachziehen
mit der inzidenz die werden auch in 14
tagen drei wochen entsprechend die
patienten auf den intensivstationen
sehen
thüringen ist im moment bei ungefähr 250
glaube ich incident sie fliegen auch
bereits patienten aus weil sie einfach
keinen platz mehr haben bei sich in der
klinik in jena
ja das ist einerseits so dass wir im
bereich der hochspezialisierten medizin
zum beispiel bei patienten bei denen
extrakorporale unterstützung der
lungenfunktion erforderlich wird mit dem
rücken an der wand stehen und auf der
anderen seite ist es so dass wir genau
bei der eco
da stehen wir mit dem rücken an der wand
haben wir keine möglichkeiten mehr diese
therapieoption auszunutzen auch bei den
jungen patienten wie geschildert müssen
wir
diese option haben und dann müssen wir
verlegen wenn wir individualmedizin ich
alle register ziehen wollen bei diesen
patienten müssen wir die patienten jetzt
verlegen und zum anderen haben wir
natürlich auch einen erheblichen engpass
bei patienten die andere diagnosen haben
als co at 19
die situation ist bei uns angespannt für
die normale intensivmedizin wenn 45
prozent der betten belegt sind mit 19
die werden ja sonst nicht leer die
betten haben wir engpässe in der
versorgung von patienten mit
tumorerkrankungen mit akuten gefäßleiden
wir sind mit dem rücken an der wand
das heißt ganz konkret dass ein
krebspatient länger auf eine ja auch
dringend notwendige operation warten
muss zum beispiel das ist korrekt dass
ist seit wochen die harte realität in
deutschen krankenhäusern
was hoffen sie sich jetzt von der von
der politik
wir haben ja auch das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz das im gespräch
ist da werden sie vermutlich als arzt
auch eine meinung zu haben
ganz sicher wir sind einerseits habe ich
eben schon die gute nachricht vorweg
genommen die impfung wirkt wir sehen die
hochbetagten patienten nicht mehr auf
der intensivstation aber bis die
impfquote in deutschland entsprechend
hoch ist gibt es nur eine chance wir
müssen kontakte reduzieren wir müssen
die entsprechenden regelungen befolgen
und die füße still halten bis die
impfquote ausreichend hoch ist sonst
gibt es sehr viele tote auch in
deutschland herr professor bauer danken
für das gespräch
vielen dank für das gespräch haben wir
vor einer stunde geführt und inmitten
dieser pandemie hat deutschland
bekanntlich noch ein zweites großes
thema
wobei es da ja auch wechselwirkungen
gibt und damit beginnen jetzt die
nachrichten von heinz wolf in der
kanzlerkandidatenfrage der union haben
sich heute mehrere
cdu-ministerpräsidenten zu wort gemeldet
reiner haseloff sachsen anhalt ist
indirekt von parteichef laschet als
kanzlerkandidat abgerückt dem spiegel
sagte haseloff
es gehe nicht um persönliche sympathie
vertrauen oder charaktereigenschaften
sondern um die harte machtfrage und die
besten chancen und damit um
popularitätswerte schleswig holsteins
regierungschef daniel günther forderte
söder dagegen zum rückzug auf und
hessens ministerpräsident bouffier sagte
im hessischen rundfunk die cdu habe das
erste zugriffsrecht das habe man gemacht
habe ein meinungsbild herbeigeführt und
daraus müsse man jetzt eine gemeinsame
entscheidung machen
der nachtragshaushalt von
bundesfinanzminister schäuble ging heute
zur ersten beratung in den bundestag
dabei verteidigte scholz die weitere
deutliche erhöhung der neuverschuldung
als unerlässlich zur erfolgreichen
bewältigung der korona pandemie
der nachtragshaushalt sieht eine
zusätzliche kreditaufnahme von rund 60
milliarden euro vor
damit kann die neuverschuldung in diesem
jahr auf einen rekordwert von rund 240
milliarden euro steigen die krone krise
reisst ein tiefes loch in den
staatshaushalt ein vorschlag führender
wirtschaftsinstitute ist jetzt das
rentenalter schrittweise auf 69 jahre
heraufzusetzen
für dieses jahr haben die
wissenschaftler ihre wachstumsprognose
deutlich gesenkt von 4,7 auf 3,7 prozent
die dritte welle treffe die wirtschaft
härter als noch im herbst angenommen
die usa weisen zehn russische diplomaten
aus und verhängen eine reihe neuer
sanktionen als reaktion auf
einmischungen in die us wahlen und einen
hacker-angriff wie die us regierung
mitteilte
unter anderem sollen es banken bestimmte
russische staatsanleihen nicht mehr
kaufen dürfen
das russische außenministerium
verurteilte die sanktionen als
ernsthaften rückschlag für die
wechselseitigen beziehungen und kündigte
eine baldige reaktion moskaus an einen
tag nach der ankündigung von
us-präsident beiden alle amerikanischen
truppen aus afghanistan abzuziehen ist
us-außenminister blinken nach kabul
gereist zu gesprächen mit der
politischen führung dort
merkel sagte afghanistan weitere
unterstützung der usa ist und bei einem
treffen mit präsident gar nicht sagte
blinken die partnerschaft verändere sich
aber die partnerschaft selbst dauere an
wenn es darum geben wurde ein preis zu
verleihen für besonders schlechtes
regierungs handwerk könnte sich der
berliner senat wohl bewerben ja war
gewarnt worden das seien mieten deckel
sonderweg juristisch nicht haltbar sein
würde
von inhaltlichen gestaltung defiziten
ganz zu schweigen
ein gesetz bei denen von anfang an sehr
fraglich ist ob es bestand haben kann
uns natürlich vor allem enorme
unsicherheit aus und zwar auf allen
seiten
rund 40 prozent der berliner vermieter
sind privatpersonen und nicht große
wohnungskonzern die kleinen vermieter
rannten anwältin die bude ein
weil sie nicht wussten was gilt und wie
sie neuvermietungen handhaben sollen
der mietmarkt brach regelrecht ein auf
der anderen seite wurden mieter
aufgefordert geld für eventuelle
nachzahlungen zurückzulegen auch das
eine absurde nebenwirkung
und nun der paukenschlag vom
bundesverfassungsgericht aus berlin sind
die ablesbar
das urteil hat die hauptstadt am morgen
mit voller wucht getroffen der mieten
deckel made in berlin wird kein
exportschlager
dabei war berlin die einzige deutsche
großstadt in der die mieten im letzten
jahr im sinkflug waren
doch das prestige-objekt dass rot rot
grünen senats ist nun abgestürzt
es ist auf jeden fall ein rückschlag da
gibt es nichts drumherum zu reden aber
das thema ist nicht weg sondern wir
haben jetzt erfahren und gerichtlich
bestätigt dass wir anders als wir
dachten die kompetenz nicht haben hier
zu regulieren das urteil des obersten
deutschen gerichts fußt auf dem
grundsatz dass bundesländer nicht regeln
dürfen was der bund bereits geregelt hat
mietrecht so die begründung sei im
bürgerlichen gesetzbuch ausreichend
geregelt
das deutschlandweit einmalige gesetz
wurde von der linkspartei gegen große
widerstände durchgeboxt für fünf jahre
sollten die mieten eingefroren und sogar
abgesenkt werden
eine notbremse gegen das marktversagen
mit der neuland betreten wurde als 1
kommen auf jeden fall sagen ist ein sehr
schwerer tag für den senat und auch die
mieterinnen und mieter von berlin
wir hatten natürlich mit allem gerechnet
dass karlsruhe jetzt so deutlich
entscheidet ist auch für uns
überraschend um 25 milliarden euro so
viel hätten laut schätzungen des senats
die berliner der 15 millionen
mietwohnungen sparen können
auch marcel und david hatten sich schon
letzten sommer im mieten deckel rechner
ihren möglichen sparbetrag ausgerechnet
28 finden wir super also freuen wird auf
jeden fall drüber als marcel dann heute
morgen las mieten decke gekippt war er
geschockt gott sei dank hatten sie das
gesparte geld erstmal zur seite gelegt
ja klar damals haben uns gefreut dass er
weniger miete zahlen müssen jetzt
eigentlich wieder so typisch politik
wird viel versprochen am ende leider
nicht gehalten oder es einfach nicht
durchdacht was du da wieder beschlossen
hatten in der vergangenheit und das
müssen wir schauen ob das geld
zurückbezahlen müssen oder nicht wütend
über die auswirkungen des urteils in
ihrer stadt rief das bündnis gegen
mietenwahnsinn am abend zu einer
spontanen demo kostet 950 euro ist erst
nächsten monat 50 euro
das bedeutet dass wahrscheinlich in zehn
jahren große vermieter wie die deutsche
wohnen haben schon angekündigt dass sie
alles zurückfordern werden nur die
window wir wir verzichten in den altbau
vierteln wo die miete per gesetz
besonders stark gesenkt wurde hatten
vermieter schon darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass das gesetz nicht
rechtssicher ist helga hofer kämpfte von
anfang an gegen den mieten deckel für
mich ist ganz klar die erste emotionale
empfindungen die ich hatte war
heute ist ein guter tag für unsere
demokratie und soziale marktwirtschaft
mit dem heutigen tag ist eigentlich
nichts anders für berlin weil das chaos
bleibt bestehen rot rot grün hat am mit
und wohnungsmarkt in den letzten fünf
jahren das chaos verstetigt es gibt
jetzt kein mieten deckel es gibt keine
mietspiegel
es gibt in dieser stadt also keinerlei
bezugspunkte und es fehlen immer noch
200.000 wohnungen in berlin also nichts
ist besser geworden auch für die
berliner grünen ein bitterer tag denn
sie hatten das gesetz mitgetragen es
gibt hier ein auftrag an den bund denn
der bund kann wenn er möchte und muss
auch dringend den ländern ermöglichen
den ländern zumindest in ländern mit so
einem angespannten wohnungsmarkt wie es
hier in berlin eben ist dass sie auch
weiterhin so was wie mieten decke machen
können denn enden wird die debatte über
bezahlbaren wohnraum auch mit dem
heutigen tage nicht ob mit oder ohne
mieten decke wenigstens gab es im
letzten jahr weniger wohnungseinbrüche
damit macht halt jetzt weiter ja das ist
ein bereich in dem die neue
kriminalstatistik für das vergangene
jahr einen rückgang verzeichnet
insgesamt wurden demnach 23 prozent
weniger straftaten registriert als 2009
so ist die zahl der wohnungseinbrüche um
13 9% zurück gesunken
zurückgegangen aber in anderen bereichen
haben die straftaten zugenommen
die polizei hat im vergangenen jahr mehr
sexuellen missbrauch an kindern
aufgedeckt die fallzahlen stiegen um 6,8
prozent hinzu kommt die befürchtung dass
viele taten aufgrund des schattens
unentdeckt bleiben
erheblich gestiegen ist auch die
kriminalität im internet jüngstes
beispiel das abgreifen von corona hilfen
mit gefälschten nutzerprofilen weil er
ja welche dimension hat der
wirtschaftliche schaden der internet
kriminalität
der schaden ist also wirklich immens
aber auch hier dürfte die dunkelziffer
hoch seien durch corona hat sich ja
vieles ins netz verlagert und das bietet
eben entsprechend mehr angriffsfläche
für kriminelle beispiel online handel in
pandemie zeiten boomt er die
kriminalität aber auch 11,5 prozent mehr
straftaten beim internet shop und
vergangenes jahr sei es bei bestellte
und bezahlte ware nie geliefert wurde
oder fälschungen als originale verkauft
wurden
zugenommen haben auch die cyber angriffe
auf unternehmen hacker dringen in it
systeme ein und legen sie lahm bis ein
lösegeld bezahlt wird ein besonderes
problem im pandemie zeiten
das home office wird zum einfallstor für
hacker
wenn die belegschaft von außerhalb auf
die systeme zugreifen können dass
cyberkriminelle potenziell auch sofern
beim schutz nicht nachgerüstet wird und
das planen nur wenige schon jetzt
vernachlässigen unternehmen cyber
risiken gerade mal zehn prozent des
it-budgets geben viele unternehmen für
sicherheit aus acht prozent der
befragten firmen haben schon eine
cyber-attacke erlebt ein viertel davon
mit schweren bis existenzbedrohenden
schäden
unternehmen sparen in der pandemie auch
an der it-sicherheit das problem
digitaler schutz kostet unternehmen
sofort und an den cyber angriff glauben
viele erst wenn er passiert ist dann
aber kann er gleich einen millionen
schaden anrichten
ballaballa vielen dank die
verkehrsminister von bund und ländern
wollen dafür ihre zweitägigen
frühjahrskonferenz den streit um die
änderungen der straßenverkehrsordnung
beilegen im fokus der neue
bußgeldkatalog mit ihm sollten unter
anderem deutlich schärfere strafen für
zu schnelles fahren durchgesetzt werden
wegen eines formfehlers wurde der
bereits geltende katalog im vergangenen
wieder außer kraft gesetzt zum zweiten
mal ist eine aufnahme des dänischen
fotografen maz niesen zum welt
pressefoto des jahres gekürt worden
das bild zeigt einen moment der korona
pandemie
das heißt die erste umarmung fünf monate
lang lebte die 85 jährige rosa lucia
lunardi isoliert in einem altenheim in
brasilien als ihre pflegerin sie nach
dieser zeit umarmt mit geschlossenen
augen und in einem schutz umhang aus
plastik wirkt sie wie ein engel
nach ansicht der jury steht das bild wie
kein anderes für die auswirkungen der
korona pandemie auf die menschen auf den
tag heute vor zwei jahren blickte die
welt nach paris
geschockt und mitfühlen angesichts des
kultur dramas das sich dort abspielte
die weltberühmte notre dame lichterloh
in flammen
die pariser bürger auf den straßen
fassungslos und hilflos präsident ma con
versprach damals umgehend dass das
nationalsymbol innerhalb von fünf jahren
wieder aufgebaut werde
und tatsächlich es hat sich schon
einiges getan
vor allem ist die kathedrale nicht mehr
einsturzgefährdet die sicherungen sollen
bis zum sommer abgeschlossen sein dann
könnte der eigentliche wiederaufbau
beginnen
dann geht es zum einen um den
mittelalterlichen dachstuhl er soll so
originalgetreu wie möglich rekonstruiert
werden ebenso der abgebrannte hölzerne
vierungsturm der erst im neunzehnten
jahrhundert auf die kathedrale gesetzt
wurde
doch es geht bei diesem großprojekt
nicht nur um alte baupläne sondern auch
um originalgetreues material vor über
850 jahren als notre dame erbaut wurde
war das neben stein vor allem holz das
beste holz dass man damals bekommen
konnte das glas berichtet
das ist alles andere als eine
gewöhnliche baustelle der der heute in
das gähnende loch im dach hinab blickt
ist kein anderer als der präsident in
schutzanzug und mit helm so wollen es
die sicherheitsvorschriften
bestandsaufnahme am zweiten jahrestag
des brandes wir sind alle beeindruckt
von dem was wir hier sehen die arbeit
dieser zwei jahre
jeder erinnert sich doch noch an das was
damals passierte alle waren aufgewühlt
das innere von notre dame eine
kathedrale aus metallgerüste vom boden
bis zum dach gewölbe hier in 25 meter
höhe fanden bauarbeiter diese stange
überrest des spitz turms der in die
tiefe gestürzt war
sehen sie diese rosen sie sind teile
einer großen krone
es gab die krone und darüber waren dass
holz und der hand der spitze turm
machtlos gegen das entfernung vor zwei
jahren notre dame
eingehüllt in flammen und rauch es ist
fast ein wunder dass sie nicht ganz
zerstört wurde dieser holzbogen ist
einer von vielen und tonnenschwer
er soll ein kreuzgewölbe abstützen dass
risse hat ins innere kommt er durch
dieses fenster dass man kurzerhand
zweckentfremdet hat er wird
millimetergenau eingepasst das ergebnis
sieht so aus wieso tust sind alle maß
getreu ausgemessen und angefertigt
worden
und weil kein gewölbe bogen gleich ist
sind auch die holzstützen alle
unterschiedlich unten in einer
seitenkapelle eine andere welt
leuchtenden farben malereien aus dem
mittelalter die bei der restaurierung
freigelegt wurden
die ganze kapelle war so schwarz wie
diese säule hier das ist die farbe die
wir kennen
durch das feuer kam noch staub dazu aber
es war schon vorher so schmutzig vom
schmutz befreien ist auch die aufgabe
dieser kletterer die sich immer wieder
in das offene dach abseilen und dort
blei staub und trümmer aufsaugen den
darauf den neuen liegen
die herausforderung ist immens nur noch
drei jahre dann so will es präsident
makro soll die kathedrale wieder
aufgebaut sein
die ganze restaurierung und der aufbau
des dachstuhls und so weiter wird
wahrscheinlich nicht abgeschlossen sein
aber man wird dann wieder betreten
können
ihr anblick erinnert jeden immer noch an
den brand es ist eben alles andere als
eine gewöhnliche baustelle allerdings
denn auch wir werden jetzt zum beispiel
100 jahre alte eichen gefällt dann im
dachstuhl verbaut zu werden
nicht nur für architekten und
restauratoren dass dieser wiederaufbau
ein faszinierendes projekt wenn sie
mögen können sie mit unserer heute app
notre dame besuchen und sich in
eigenregie und 360 grad in der tat
kathedrale umschauen wie sie vor dem
brand aussah und interaktiv im 3d modell
wie es auf der baustelle weiter gehen
soll
und hier geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit
maybrit illner und ihren gästen zu denen
unter anderem olaf scholz christian
lindner und karl lauterbach gehören und
sie ahnen es debattiert wird über corona
und die notbremse und um 0.30 meldet
sich an der zimmermann wird dem
heute-journal update bis morgen aber
wieder sehr wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter luft kommt
allmählich aus östlichen richtungen und
bringt uns regen und sogar etwas schnee
mit
und es gibt vor allem viele wolken es
wird weniger sonnenschein geben schauen
wir uns erst mal die nacht an und da
gibt es von osten her kompakte wolken
mit regen und schnee vor allem im
erzgebirge und richtung vogtland
vorsicht glätte auch in tieferen lagen
im nordwesten klart es verbreitet auf
und die temperaturen sinken auf minus
fünf grad an den alpen und drei grad an
der nordsee morgen vor allem im
nordwesten viel sonnenschein teilweise
bis richtung schleswig holstein auch
richtung emsland und rein ansonsten im
osten ist es dichter bewölkt mit etwas
regen und richtung erzgebirge und
richtung vogtland ist etwas schnee dabei
am main kann es etwas tröpfeln viel wird
es nicht sein
an den alpen gibt es nur wenige wolken
und vor allem im allgäu viel
sonnenschein die temperaturen steigen
bis auf 4 grad im vogtland und 12 grad
im nordwesten deutschlands schauen wir
auf die nächsten tage
am samstag kommen immer noch kompakte
wolken von osten her
allerdings ist regen und schnee nur noch
wenig dabei das wird nicht viel sein
im westen ist es teils noch nicht bei 4
bis 13 grad am sonntag gibt es vor allem
im süden und norden schauer bei sechs
bis vierzehn montag im süden wiederum
schauer
dafür steigen die temperaturen auf 16
grad damit ein schöner abend